welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and today we're breaking
down Deadpool
2 it lives up to the hype Plus+ [__] it
they probably won't even make a three
yeah why would they stop it too you
killed him teas in the post credit scene
for part one this sees cable appearing
in the film played by none other than
Josh Brolin Brolin was also in the role
of Thanos which even gets a little joke
later in the movie zip it Thanos we have
a deal you [__] the sequel ideas were
in the works even before the first film
relased which is why we got the tear at
the end Simon kinberg worked on a number
of X-Men films and said that he wanted
to bring in cable for a long time they
were floating around him showing up in
Days of Future Past but after all that
fell through it gave room for Deadpool
the sequel had yet to be green L but the
creative still started brainstorming
things early after that the first film
was such a big hit Reynolds had extra
clout and because they hadn't drawn up
contracts he had a big big opportunity
in the end he negotiated more creative
control and had complete casting
approval this caused Tim Miller to step
back as he felt he and Reynolds clashed
over where to take the movie he wanted
to take things more in line with the
first one and have it be slightly more
grounded than what Reynolds was planning
he also wanted Gina corano to return and
for car chanler to be in the role of
cable Vanessa would also have further
development and become copycat like how
she is in the comics Marina bakaran also
said she felt like the character was a
victim of fridging with this term
originating from Green Lantern 52 in
case you don't know Kyle rer found his
girlfriend's body in the fridge with
that then becoming his driving force in
the story bridging basically means when
a female character is introduced just to
be killed off so that they can help the
main character have motive in the story
Riders R recent Paul wck denied this
though and said they had no idea what
fridging was and originally she was just
going to break up with him this was
obviously Chang though and lastly in
Miller's version Juggernaut would fight
the thing with Fox even approving use of
the character on the other side of this
Reynolds wanteded the humor turned up to
11 and to take things in a different
direction with cable by the end of part
one he also mentioned these names the
sequel we're going to have cable just
need a big guy with a flat top could be
Mel Gibson Dolph lungren Kiera knly
lungren was really interested as well
and he posted fan out of himself on
Instagram posing as the character not
sure if that was just a joke or what but
other people involved included Michael
Shannon David Harper screen tested for
it too with PS broen also getting close
as well Brad Pit was almost really close
to her to but scheduling issues ended up
in the way he said to MTV News he'd
taken the superhero genre as far as
could take it and thank Reynolds for
giving him a role that he was able to
bring Justice to in the end it of course
went to Brawlin and it's going to be
interesting to see if he comes back down
the line he has signed on for a full
pitcher deal with the now being three
more appearances he's obligated to make
as for the other aspects it apparently
caused conflict at the studio and fox
chose Reynolds of melo's wishes this
then brought in Domino with a role being
highly sought after or Plaza she almost
got out with zzy Beats winning out in
the end John Wick's David Leech was
brought on to D with that distinctive
action style being present in the movie
that gets a little ND in the opening
credits when we can see his name is
listed as one of the guys who killed
John Wick's dog never forget never
forget the budget was also double to 110
million but there were a number of
things that they couldn't get to work Mr
Rex was initially going to be the
villain but they felt out they couldn't
balance him with the others present it
was also black Tom Cassidy and Slugger
as well but their roles were cut down to
be just minor ones in the movie and the
movie was released with three different
versions firstly there was the
theatrical which also dropped on Blu-ray
and along with that came the super duper
Extended Cut that's the version I'm
going to be watching for this breakdown
as that has the most details in it there
was also a Christmas PG-13 version
released as well but yeah we're going
hard and uncut for this one now we begin
as always with the Marvel logo which
then transitions into a lighter sparking
up we then see Deadpool smoking a
cigarette which he'll use in just a
minute to blow himself up we can also
catch him winding up a musical toy of
wolverines speared on a branch like his
dead scene in Logan this ends up coming
full circle in the final scene as they
use the same music in both Deadpool and
Logan's death there's one out there for
you just keep looking
okay Deadpool also says [__] Wolverine
first he rides my coattails with the r
then the hairy [__] UPS the
Annie by dying and I love this tongue
and joke and to be fair you have to
admit that Deadpool opened up the door
for allr comic book movies according to
Insider a fox it was only once I saw how
well Deadpool there that they decided to
go that Direction with Wolverine now we
look about the apartment and can see
some momentos from the first film there
Wade wearing a cap like how he did at
the lawn room at and also a shot of
Vanessa and Wade's first date we can
also see them wearing Christmas hats
with that first film originally being
set during Christmas there's also a
Canadian flag with Reynolds of course
being from the Country Canada in the
background we can hear the song All Out
of Love by Air Supply which Reynolds
also suang in Van Wilder before blowing
up we can see his blue colored Crocs
which were also something that he wore
in the first film both him and Vanessa
are also shot in the heart which
symbolically brings her two deaths
together C to six weeks Pride with
Deadpool going on a killing spree and we
get a shot of a skyscraper with a
Japanese sign on it these characters
roughly translate to Deadpool with a
first of them being death that also Taps
into the themes of this movie with way
Longing To Die so he can go be with
Vanessa listening to xon give it here
this song of course appeared in the
first movie before the final battle
there it was used to highlight there
were X-Men possessing an X Gene coming
from Xavier's Mansion here is used to
amp himself up much in the same way she
was used in the first film we can catch
our little portable player here too with
it having we written on it like how it
did last time calling his Target he then
pulls up a card which according to Du 18
on Reddit has the word redus on it redus
is a villain from the comics with him
being a mutant who ran the Sydney Tri
Riot cutting up the forces to Dolly
Parton's 9 to5 it really sets a to for
this montage and after slicing them up
we see him popping out a coffin which
reminded me a lot of the level in the
PS2 Punisher game it's the
Punisher Deadpool also references Ace
Ventura do not go in there do not go in
there woo and the xend cut has a line
about Captain America well let's see
Captain America do that cut to the strip
club and we then see him wearing a
blonde Wick in heels this was put in to
be a not a Lady Deadpool with it also
being rumored she'll appear in the third
film according to a bath house in Osaka
this was extended for the longer cut
with us getting the camera rotating
around him several times leech was gut
it they had to cut it for the theatrical
one as it took a lot of work and it
really shows a step up from the first
film they're way more creative with the
staging here including him chasing a
dealer through a warehouse which is all
done in one take we then see him with
his Adventure Time watch which is also
something that he had in the first film
could him running to to the taxi in a
shot that resembles the beginning of
Raiders of the Lost talk here we see do
penda listening to a Tony Robin
self-help tape with this being some at
drives him throughout the movie now in
case you missed our first video delinder
was someone Reynolds named after a kid
he went to school with who unfortunately
died after being struck by lightning
Deadpool also calls dopinder goose with
him being the co-pilot from Top Gun Tom
Cruz films get reference throughout the
movie with him constantly bringing up
Interview with a Vampire and then
remember the movie Interview with a
Vampire I want to when Tom Cru for
10-year-old kirston DS blood for the
first time one of Ryan's early films
Dick had him making out with her and
Brad Pit of course also stared in that
movie too here he also brings up how
he's now mentioned in the same sentence
as Jesus no I'm talked about in the same
sentence as Jesus Passion of the Christ
then me with this referring to the box
office returns in which passion was the
highest ARR movie domestically whereas
Deadpool Beat It abroad going back home
we see his Deadpool gets out the taxi
and can catch on the advert that this is
for Alpha flight there's a Canadian
maple leaf flag there as well with Alpha
flight being a Canadian comic team
Deadpool end says you're right I was
fighting a caped badass then we
discovered his mom is named Martha too
why did you say that name you get that
one you get it however the plot of this
movie also somewhat plays off those
versus type movies because we have two
Heroes fighting each other that then
have to team up he also gives finessa an
arcade token which is where the pair had
their first date again it comes full
circle as it's kind of what brings them
together due to how they talk comes
around again at the end Vanessa says her
baby Factory is open and the writers
confirmed there was a script where they
had a son however however they realized
that due to the humor it just wouldn't
work and they ended up exercising it
from the plot they then sit down and
watch yentel with Wade constantly
pointing out how it sounds just like
frozen Papa can you see me does this
song sound familiar to you Do You Want
to Build a
Snowman the creative team ended up
kicking themselves on the commentary as
they realized that Boba stren's married
to Josh Brolin dad James you know James
braw in mate you've seen Westworld it
looks like Christian Bale throughout the
entire thing but either way they said
they'd completely forgotten to include
it even though it would have been a
perfect meta joke Deadpool later wears
chunks of wine shirt from The Goonies
which he has when he's talking to Cable
apparently that was something he also
forgot to mention and brol and himself
didn't even put two and two together
however Deadpool does call
him give me your best shot one i' Willie
which is a reference to the pirate from
The Goonies so I at least I didn't miss
that and Wade then Compares his issues
to look in Star Wars which Vanessa then
corrects to being Empire maybe that's
Empire this is a callback to this line
from the first film Star Wars jokes
Empire the whole discussion here is
about how kids make you a better person
which in many ways Russell ends up doing
you see Deadpool putting some food in
the microwave with the shots set up
being the same as right before he Bloom
himself up this brings a Moment full of
circle and his death or attempt at it
mirrors vanessas grabbing her killer and
standing in front of a moving vehicle we
then C to a James B ESC opening scene I
felt like there was a bit of a reference
to Bon in the first film when way
introduced himself as this H do in there
pool dead this song is of course sang by
celion and it was also used to help with
the pacing Lee Fell if they went from
Vanessa's death straight into the story
that it would feel like it didn't carry
impact however doing this gives it room
to breathe and thus we can feel the
weight of her passing during this we can
catch his swords coming towards the
camera and on the bottom can see the
words B Deadpool's swords and name both
be and Arthur because the character is a
big fan of Golden Girls He also wore her
T-shirt with a face on it in the first
film and as I've been saying it's all
connected now if you think it's all
connected then make sure you check out
our Kevin figy shirt right below the
video all goes towards helping videos
like this get made and you'll get at
least one you made out of it me so good
luck with that and thank you now just
like the first movie all the credits
listed here are little tongue and- cheek
jokes about what's going on most of them
are just shock reactions and anger of
Vanessa being killed one even saying
Ryan Reynolds didn't want to share this
Spotlight realizing David Leech directed
this movie it also made that little one
about John Wick's dog hit a bit more
never forget the writers are also known
as The Heroes of the first one but here
they get a little diss on themselves the
cinematography is carried out by blind
Al and we also see on the front of
Deadpool's gun that it says smile and
then wait for the flash he also doesn't
not to flash dance with a chair push and
we also see a bull in the arcade tokens
showing how the movie is going to end
from here we C to the Sister Margaret
school for away with girls bar which was
a playoff Xavier school for gifted
youngsters W says George Michael's right
I'm never going to dance again on the
first film of course ended with him and
Vanessa kissing in a Careless Whisper
help by Buck this character returns from
the first film with him then telling
away the five stages of grief Jesus
Christ Buck no more speaking lines for
you just killed me that bit cuz the guy
the guy's delivery so bad according to
the Kubler Ross yeah according to the
kuer Ross model Deadpool endings at at
the floorboards and we can see two
things that he talked about in the first
film and also um there's about 116 kilos
of cocaine buried somewhere in the
apartment right next to the cure for
blindness love way you've got that cure
for blindness there and blind Al sits
down and pulls out her gun this is the
same one way took from her in the first
film and it's also the one that he used
to kill Francis with she tells him to
keep living you need to just keep living
oh sh's right now he B right now he
pointing out this is a reference to
Matthew mccon and da and confused you
got to keep living man shut the up Ryan
ER trying to destroy himself in as many
ways as possible we see him initially
diving into a Polar Bear Pit he also
jumps off a building after drinking clog
cleaner and this has Agent K written at
the bottom this is a nod to Josh
Brolin's character Men in Black 3 and he
says that he needs to die harder let
trademark Fox with Fox of course owning
the rights of that franchise don't
reboot it whatever don't please don't
reboot it this Montage actually builds
off the back of the first film as we
were going to get something similar in
that in a deleted scene when Wade goes
to tell Vanessa he's alive he was then
going to step out and get hit by a bus
this would then spiral out into a grand
Hog Day inspired Montage in which he'd
keep offing himself and then waking up
in the morg grabbed by Colossus Wade's
then taken to the X mansion which is of
course appeared throughout the franchise
and also in Arrow from here we then jump
to asex house with us getting an
extended scene of this in the super
duper cut kind of feel like this is a
metaphor for stuff like conversion
therapy with them wanting to turn
mutants back to being humans at the 36
minute Mark the guy removes his tie and
it's clear that LE into some other
uniforms used in religion Essex House is
also no to Nathaniel Essex who in the
comics is Mr Sinister Essex Corp have
appeared throughout the franchise as
they're the ones who grab Wolverine's
blood in X-Men apocalypse this in itself
was used to create Deadpool with
droplets of blood being spotted in the
syringe Julian Dennison was also the
only person considered for the role of
Russell with Ryan crafting the part for
him after seeing him in Hunt for the
Wilder people in that his character
Ricky wears a hoodie with a similar one
being brought into this film Russell
alsoa constantly talks about the
gangster alive which is something that
Ricky does too we're like thugs we're
like gangsters I'm like tog par and
you're like ice cube waking up on a
couch you can then see two cats on
Deadpool's t-shirt these are Olivia and
Meredith which are actually Taylor
Swift's cats Swift's been mat with
Reynolds and his wife Blake Lively with
her including a sample of one of their
daughters on the song gorgeous Swift War
one of Reynolds Deadpool costumes on
Halloween ones and it's also rumored
she's going to play daor and Deadpool 3
I'm making this before seeing the
trailer or the movie so if you're from
the future and know if she's then leave
it in the comments below lots of time
traveling stuff right now anyway Nega
Sonic teenage Warhead is back from the
first film and this time she's with her
girlfriend yukoh Deadpool calls her
especially Pinkie Pie from My Little
Pony with this potentially revealing
that he's secretly a brony in the comic
she's typically a lot older but they
wanted to lower her age for her
relationship with Nega Sonic we can see
that the two also drink out of cups that
both say I'm with her and have an arrow
underneath it Deadpool calls Nega Sonic
11 throughout the film and this is of
course a reference to stranger things
they actually wanted her to have a
shaved head again with it burning off
whenever she activated her powers
however Brianna Helder brand was working
on another project and thus I just kept
it at this Mohawk we see Deadpool
spinning around in Professor X's chair
and we were going to get a deleted scene
where I tried on cerebro it's a big
house it's funny that I only ever see
two of you it's almost like the studio
couldn't afford another X-Men which
plays off yeah where the [__] is
everyone it's always just you Nega Sonic
teenage longest name ever Al you can see
blood of X-Men members in one of the
classrooms this includes Evan Peters
Ralph Bon sorry stupid that stupid who
would ever do that Evan peters's
Quicksilver and James makavo Professor X
this clears up the confusion from the
first film in which Deadpool wondered
what timeline he was in let us go talk
to the professor makoy or Stewart these
timelines are so confusing Quicks is
also wearing an Avon t-shirt which was M
toties that the next X-Men film would
take place in the '90s this was actually
shut alongside dark Phoenix which is why
the cats were able to come together for
what a couple seconds long shot you also
have Beast Nightcrawler storm and
cyclops these were them in their 80s and
9 stuff and this is set in the 2010s but
yeah lots of timey wiy wibbly wobbly
stuff and let's be honest Fox don't care
too much about continuity they actually
went this direction due to apocalypse
and for the fact that Patrick Stewart
had just been in Logan that was said to
be his final appearance but as we know
he'd return for the MCU he also brings
up angel but how about that pots with
the giant pigeon wings now this point we
me cable then basking him in a purple
light little nod to Thanos by the
creative team but what we see is a world
akin to the one from Days of Future Past
we learned that his family were kill and
he constantly carries round a burn Teddy
Bear this two show up in the opening
credit scene and it's used as a way to
show whether the future is fixed or not
this is something I Back to the Future
did a lot with there being lots of items
that change out the trilogy we've
covered all those films on the channel
and definitely check them out if you
want to see us dive into them now the
time travel stuff they do here is sort
of akin to Terminator with cable
traveling through time to try and kill
Russell Deadpool at one point calls him
John Connor and the S his gun makes when
recharging was taken from Terminator 2
cable also has a scene staring at
himself in the mirror which riffs off
the back of when Onie cut his eye out
later on cable also spins his gun to
[__] it and it's similar how terminated
did it when riding on the motorbike the
days of future pass adopted the whole
going back in time to change things but
instead of trying to kill someone they
were trying to stop that from happening
that's something he said was more in
line with Professor X but C he's just a
bloody Cold Blood killer now Russell is
said to be the mutant Antichrist which
in itself comes from the comics that
played out in the kid apocalypse Arc
which itself was a part of uncanny
xforce in the comics Cable's infected
with a technorganic virus and this makes
him able to tap into machines he also
has cybernetic parts and is very much a
child of the '90s now speaking of being
a child he's also sort of the son of
Cyclops and Gene gray I think I'm not
fully up on all of law right now but
last scene which was like years ago he's
sort of a clone son cuz Cyclops was his
dad and meline prior AKA Jean Gray's
clone that was his mother I think it's
all over the place but we get an OD to
the PRI later in the prison truck scene
as we can see a van with PRI on the side
of it according to amdb trivia leech
wanted to include more of his backstory
but they ended up scrapping it because
it was just too convoluted we were going
to get a photo with Cyclops and cable St
a hope but this raised too many
questions and thus it was cut hope sum
is is actually a big character in the
com makes with her being labeled as the
mutant Messiah hoping we get to Meer one
day in the movies and that we get a live
action Avengers versus X-men that's with
the creepy dirty hobo bear it's my
daughter's teddy bear her name's Hope
anyway one of my favorite things about
what they do with cable isn't in the
film and it comes from the meat cable
trailer maybe the kind that leaves you
more machine the man wait no stop what
in the actual ass deal why why why are
the visual effects not done it's a metal
arm it's not like we're trying to remove
a mustache just always kills me that and
I wish they' left it in the movie
somehow with it being a nod to the
nightmare that was Justice League his
time travel device is made from a call F
buera watch with his also appearing in
leeches of the films those were John
Wick 2 and atomic blonde but I couldn't
find out why he keeps on using them we
see him flickering through moments in
time and this includes a shot of the
Blackbird this is it later coming over
the trees with this showcasing it's at
the Essex House traveling back he goes
to these two guys with them being pretty
big cameos these are Alan T and Matt
Damon Damon's got a fake beard and beard
belly and facial Prosthetics and and the
first time I seen him I didn't fully
recognize him if you didn't then you're
not the only one as I'm theb trivia
States at the camera crew didn't either
now imagine being told you'd work with M
Damon and then had no idea until he left
the set Chumps even in the credits the
character's name says Dicky Greenleaf
which is a little nut of the identity he
steals in the Talented Mr Ripley now the
whole idea for this bit came from an
argument R Reese has been making for
years and apparently Ryan Reynolds just
had to put it in the movie they thought
the best thing to do was get a highly
esteemed actor to deliver the pitch and
Reynolds then reached out to Damon Damon
got so far into the role that he
apparently is now a wet wipes guy he's a
method actor and to be fair I am too and
don't add me in the comments until
you've tried it we're trying to sell you
that as well now this is obviously why
right now he's got more subscribers than
me but at this point cable steals a
sixpack of beer huge shout outs to
monster can on rdit for pointing out
that one of the first things cable does
in the comics is form the group six-pack
he then also Robs a gun store which is
sumon The Terminator did in his first
movie the Extended Cut we then get a
scene where he takes a canister out the
fridge and then puts us down next to
some name badges one of them says Wheels
which is a nod to what Logan called
Professor Rex the first time they met
Colossus also says H something wrong
with the soap that's fine just filled it
give it a few more pumps there which
hilariously plays off later in the movie
movie people think you wake up a hero
ejaculate into a soap dispenser a
hero cutting to Deadpool reading a book
this is the Canadian Mounted which John
candi's character also read in Planes
Trains and Automobiles watching a news
report we can then see the teker has a
couple of cool details the first talks
about how there's abnormally high winds
expected in the downtown area which
later leads to the death of xforce the
one that follows it is about how
Christopher Plumber refused to do
re-shoot which is a little joke about
all the money in the world on that he
replace Kevin spicy where the actors
scenes all being reshot now outside the
Essex House we then meet Russell who's
based on the comic character fire fist
we then hear the reporter's name is
Irene Merryweather who is a reporter
that comes from the comics later on she
appears during the X4 scene and she's in
the helicopter that kills Shadow star we
then see his Deadpool who becomes a
traine for the X-Men calling back to
this line from the first film so what
you're like uh he sidekick no try
Stanley apparently hated Sidekicks and
this is why you don't really see many at
Marvel he then says for the X-Men dated
metaphor for racism in the' 60s well
that basically being what Stanley
created them for with them being a
metaphor for prejudice Deadpool asks if
the fire fist burns from the elbow and
later on we see guest right Russell's
powers can be seen originating from his
elbows and then moving up his wrists
directly into the fists but I'm not a
rapper we then get this line come
quietly or there will be trouble you
stole it from RoboCop Rubble cop a
Deadpool's stealing a line from the film
during the first movie Dead are alive
you're coming with me dead are alive you
are coming with me Deadpool then gets
thrown into a nearby building and he
autographs a box of hero Flakes with
Wolverine on it Deadpool signs this is
Ryan Reynolds which yeah I don't know
why but guessing it's cuz he's so used
to signing things that he automatically
does it or it's it's a joke and I'm just
bloody stupid you we get the joke there
anyway but the kid here is played by the
same kid who plays David Hower and the
X-Men show Legion without being being
connected to this people have also done
a theory time the time that they might
be the same character now if you love
the classics then definitely check out
our partners Arrow who have a ton of
amazing 4K Blu-rays on their site
they've just released carry which I
watch today brilliant have Robo Cop in
there too and are also dropping Invasion
of the Body Snatchers which is a film
I'm going to cover use the code heavy
spoilers at check out for 10% off that's
heavy spoilers at check out for 10% off
shabow the Deadpool Enders a superhero
Landing which he has difficulty getting
up from this is obviously and nodded
this bit from the first film with it
being really unpractical and bad on your
knees oh [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] oh
that is so
unpractical w superhero Landing yeah
that's really hard on your knees totally
impractical they all do it quoting that
film even further Deadpool Enders the
four or five moments speech that
Colossus did in the first one four or
five
moments I'm sorry four or five moments
that's all it takes [__] it four or five
that's all it takes shooting the orderly
that he referred to as Jared Kushner
this makes Colossus realize that he's
not Xmen material now wayen Russell are
sent to the ice box which is a Canadian
super prison that comes from the comics
originally in the first film they wanted
to use the raft and a sign for it even
shot up in a delate scene however they
scrapped that after being worried about
Marvel who were also featuring it during
Civil War as the an you can also see a
guy with green head doing a slow collap
which is sort of a combo of Heath leder
Joker and the jaro version as we see the
inmates there's one with long white hair
and we know from the behind scenes stuff
that this is Omega Red that can be seen
on a scene on YouTube and apparently he
was going to have more to do here
however they ended up cutting him out
along with another mutant in Abyss you
also get a quick shot of black Tom
Cassidy which somewhat foreshadows
Jugger or arrival in the car makes the
pair often team up as for this movie he
of course sides with Russell he also get
a not to the Sorting Hat from Harry
Potter with Deadpool hoping he gets to
be in a gang cut a cable and there's a
ticker outside his room which we get
constant cuts to managed to read one of
them and it says cuddling a kitten every
day come be good for you which he I'm
finally I'm glad we're finally getting
the message out there with a color on
Deadpool the cancer comes back and it's
completely stripped him of his powers
however he doesn't want to escape
because this will finally let him be
with Vanessa approached by black Tom
Cassidy Russell enser pulling out a pen
which we saw in the opening credit scene
Deadpool gets the crap kicked out of him
and as he says he's basically Hawkeye
and we then further references to Marvel
when Deadpool says this grumpy old
[__] with a Winter Soldier arm this
takes the fight to the shower scene and
as Deadpool walks around we can catch a
sign up on the back this says conduct
cavity searches without warning which
yikes who are you I'm thatman which is a
reference to this what are
you I'm Batman and
this I'm Batman W also says this and
makes fun of his pouches D [__]
you're so dark do sh I'm from the DC
Universe that dubstep line is a consum
back and forth they have whether it's
still a thing in the future this sets up
scrille X's Bangarang which plays over
the fight scene here and later on the
Convoy Deadpool also says he has a lot
of pouches which is something Rob lifel
got criticized for cuz all his
characters had tons and tons of pouches
however over the years he's come to
embrace it and even signs pouches at
conventions as he sees it as a good
thing people who are bugged by it they
nitpick it and you know a couple weeks
ago I put up um all the pictures
of things in pop culture or things in
reality that have pouches SWAT SWAT
units guys in the military field have
pouches isn't that funny they have
pouches I guess when my military guys
have pouches it's not such a big leap
but it's easy and you know what I love I
love when people in The Last 5 Years
it's happened a lot they bring me
pouches to sign brand spanking newb
pouches and I sign them or I draw them
that's cool I you know what I made a
nich for myself you identify that with
me something you know how many artists
would love to be identified period after
Deadpool pulls a pin on ca's explosive
they're blown outside and we get this
returning line from the first film Rock
meet bottom rock meet bottom both ended
with Wade falling into something with a
water here taking him to Vanessa
realizing that it's Russell who's going
to make him a better person he then
crawls outside and returns to the bar
but then start to brainstorm recruiting
a team that can also carry the franchise
for 15 years I'm talking about some
oceans 14 [__] Rogue 2 John Wick 3 with
the original director my little slide
dig there as though Chad stalsky
directed John Wick 1 2 3 and four leech
was actually co- director on the first
film however it's stalsky who tends to
get the soul credit and no I think they
mate you know he's just thrown a little
joke out about it because he often gets
overlooked now back in the prison
Russell goes through the Jugger or with
him realizing he has to befriend the
biggest guy there instead of beating him
up at this point Wade and weasel go to
recruit X force with their first profile
being Ruth Bader Ginsburg we then meet
Bam from The X Force comics and he's
played by Terry Cruz Deadpool says he's
basically Dave Matthews because he can
cause pain and anxiety by distorting
electrical Fields later on when bam dies
he says no tripping billies without
being a song by the Dave Matthews Band
we then meet Z who's played by Bill scar
good Rob Delaney plays Peter Lewis tan
also pops of his shadow star Brad Pitt
is the vanisher and lastly zazzy beats
his Domino she refused to shave on pits
for the film as she said she wanted to
smash the stereotypes that it was weird
and gross according to IB trivia they
envisioned her powers as being like a
rude Goldberg machine on steroids in
which everything seems to fall into
place perfectly it all just works out
for her which Deadpool describes as a
2008 Ryan Reynolds we then learned that
shadow star is from Mojo World which is
also a place that comes from the comics
Shadow star being an alien is also
confirmed to us when he gets cut up and
sprays green blood being an alien
basically makes him better at everything
than everyone else and in the end he's
sort of like a Superman Wade says that
he wants to find a Planet like that with
weel and saying isn't Canada you shut
your goddamn trash mouth again Reynolds
is obviously Canadian so you you got to
stick up with them I like Canada been to
Toronto five times and it was Bloody
brilliant now shut up for a second yeah
I don't fully get the Presley versus K
in reference in the back right but
apparently when Elvis was younger he
went to a hardware store and tried to
buy a gun a man named Alan KAS convinced
to get a guitar instead and as they say
the rest is history not sure why they're
fighting but on top of this there's also
a lot of funny stuff that they did to
mess with the audience they ended up
shooting additional action moments just
for the trailer with the X force and
this was to hide from the audience
exactly what was going to happen in an
interview with Business Insider Cruz
told them they had to wear blankets and
be shuffled in and off set so that would
further go to make people think
something big was happening he said he
felt bad because of how excited some
fans got but also love that the joke was
that they all got killed straight away
their fad is hinted to us when their
profiles are put up on the wall as
there's knives in their photos whereas
Domino gets a pin Peter's also a great
stand out as well who had a social media
account at the time that used to tweet
out really Bland stuff Reynolds was
actually behind most of it and it was
such a good way to help Market the film
now from here we cut of the prisoners
getting sent out the ice box while cable
interrogates weasel he reveals they're
going to Jerry Dugen Parkway which is
named after a Deadpool Rider who was
working on the book while the film was
being made he also warns them there's a
win advisory in effect which is why
cable doesn't come from the sky I warn
you there's a wind advisory in
effect little turbulent up here could a
Deadpool going through the plan and we
also get a really cool Wolverine Easter
egg Deadpool has him drawn in a cage
Hawking back to his timeout Weapon X
however above that we can see some
writing that says prisoner
2461 that's a number Jean valj gets
given when he's locked up in lamea and
the character was played by Hugh Jackman
in the recent movie adaptation we can
also see below it that it says DMC
prison with DMC appearing on the trucks
when they went to get Russell guessing
this is like the department for damage
control but instead of that it's the
department for mutant control you can
also catch squl money with them saying
there's no need for a third act these
are joing about how the sequel got way
more money so they could add in some big
action scenes in the first film they had
$7 million taken off the budget at the
last minute and thus they had to cut out
a big motorbike chase this made the
creative team then rearrange the script
and spread the first action seen
throughout most of the movie Deadpool
then announces that he was always always
appalled by the the sexism in the name
X-Men and he was angry that they weren't
called X people I don't know if this is
making fun of Victoria Alonzo who called
the name out dated or the dark Phoenix
saying it should be called ex women
pretty sure this was released before
that but either way it's play tongue and
cheek and and making fun of people who
demand stuff is always PC and he says
their name will be xforce with these
scenes having lots of references to
their comics Domino calls it derivative
and that's what they were labeled at the
time with them being thought of as a way
to revive the X-men with some new blood
the series also had a big relaunch in
issue 116 with a containing a mission in
which they all got killed the leader was
zidge without being his only ever
appearance which is why he has a tattoo
that says 116 later on Deadpool's suit
also gets burned and turns gray similar
to what he wore in his ex Force run
Deadpool then looks at the camera and
says Le hit it which is a reference to
the costume guy that work on the movie
we then hear the song Thunder Struck by
ACDC which could be a not iron man
jumping out of a plane to the band song
during a second film according time to
be trivia Army Captain David Blakeley of
the Pathfinder platoon used to play this
when the Pathfinders carried out jumps
the scene was apparently inspired by a
real life event that happened to
Reynolds when the actor went skydiving
apparently his parachute failed to open
on the first try and since then he's had
a phobia of skydiving as X Force descend
from the sky we can also see that they
line up in an X formation Domino's the
one who pulls her shoot last and this is
why she avoids most of the wind
initially they also wanted them to land
in a Minefield but they couldn't explain
why one would be there everyone gets
killed though and as we see Deadpool
lands against a sign that says Hillside
according Tob trivia this was the
original title of 15 which was the first
film that Ryan Reynolds starred in we
can also see another reference to spinal
tap with a sign saying puppet show at
noon spinal tab opened up for a puppet
show and Deadpool here is also hanging
like a puppet it when Ze I is pulled
into the wood chipper you can also catch
the name jepetto which is a reference to
Pinocchio's father Deadpool says the bad
news is everyone's dead but the good
news is no one's going to miss Shadow
star that's because he was a bit of a
prick as he says but them also been a
[__] in the comics who doesn't
subscribe to YouTube channels Deadpool
then steals a red scooter which is an
odd to Deadpool 68 as Domino comes in we
then get our Stanley Cameo as we can see
his face upon a mural you can also spot
a sign that says betini Boulevard V
named after the visual effects artists
who worked on this scene here we see
Domino's powers in full effect with
Deadpool mocking them for probably not
being very cinematic have to admit when
I first heard about her powers being
locked I had no idea what that even
meant sounded stupid but seeing it play
out it just it works brilliantly and
it's one of the coolest set of powers
I've seen Deadpool also says I mean luck
I mean what C out fre show comic book
artist came up with that little Chestnut
probably a guy who can't draw feet which
is him making fun of Deadpool Creator
Rob leld who often got criticized
because he didn't draw feet very well
lorts of YouTube videos talking about it
and he'd often use smoke as a way to
help cover them I like the guy so not
not going to slag him off and apparently
life I love the joke as well cable then
grinds down the wall using his arm which
is similar how Hulk also Moves In The
Avengers jumping on the Convoy he gets
on board and here we see several other
mutants back here is black Tom Cassidy
and we also get a cameo by director
David Leech however I bet you didn't
know that the face model used for Jugger
or was also provided by leech this was
then stretched out and Reynolds did his
voice because they didn't have the
budget to pay for anyone else this is
why the credits list the Juggernaut as
himself with Reynolds also providing the
motion capture we then get a scene of
domino fighting against cable with this
being an opposite to how it is in the
comics there she was introduced as a
former girlfriend of kall and it was
Deadpool that she in fact hated speaking
of opposit the comics have her with
white skin with a black circle around
her eye whereas here they switch it up
this is sort of like a domino itself as
you tend to get black and white ones
with a color switched on them apparently
during the scenes zzy beats also fainted
with the leather suit cutting off her
oxygen she said that the suit was wildly
impractical and a not so bloody luy are
you hey SH now when Deadpool gets on
board we also get on to X-Men Origins
with Deadpool slicing through a bullet
like how he did in that film leech
wanted to cut the followup where he
fails to stop several of them but
Reynolds found it hilarious and insisted
they kept it in when we get a shot from
the side you can see the bu are hitting
him and this is by all the blood coming
out his back as the truck crashes
Deadpool teabags cable which is not of
the opening of the first film when he
did the same thing that Ajax henchman
Deadpool ends up with his head on back
to front and after turning around he
says suck it mil Gibson that was added
in for the super duper car and it's a
reference to a lethal weapon in which
his character rigs constantly get a
dislocated shoulder Deadpool en reals
off how he's a massive fan of Juggernaut
and he brings up the following Comics
Uncanny X-Men 183 which has Juggernaut
versus Colossus on the cover this of
course foreshadows the end and he also
mentions Thor 411 don't know why I keep
saying it like that I'll just say Thor
41 s like an idiot but that has
Juggernaut versus Thor on the cover with
them going head-to-head with Jonathan
it's also X-Men unlimited 12 which
ironically sees him as a prisoner
Deadpool L says you know it has always
been a dream of mine to see my face
reflected in your helmet as you charge
at me with murderous intent a shout outs
to Kristen on Reddit for pointing out
that this is a reference to a big
Deadpool cover here we can catch
Deadpool reflected in the helmet of
Jugger whilst he charges towards him
with murderous intent juger ends up
tearing W in har with this then getting
a clear reference to The Empire Strikes
Back Domino carries him on his back
which is just like how chewbaca carried
C3PO back home his legs start to
regenerate with Reynolds being the one
that pinned most to this scene Blake
Lively apparently came up with the
phrase sh coocking which is something
she she'd said to Reynolds before won't
imagine why that was but we can also
catch the unicorn toy in the couch which
way could be seen holding in the first
film during that fast forward scene
don't don't look at what he's doing I
said don't look Deadpool then says PPP
it black Black Widow I'm flowing which
is a reference to well well you get it
um with sco also being reynolds's
ex-wife cable and arrives and W his a
Basic Instinct and Crosses his legs
which gets called out by weasel here
they have the baby Hitler de Bay which
is then something that gets brought up
in the post credit scene now this was C
from the theatrical release and that was
because it got a poor response at test
screenings the creative team didn't want
people leaving with a negative feeling
about the movie and instead they shifted
using the device to fix real world
mistakes however the super dup allowed
them to add it back in and I think it's
a hilarious way to play out one of the
most asked time traveled questions of
all time the scene also really shows us
how similar that Deadpool and cable are
the ladder lost the people that he loved
to and Vanessa's death is similar to his
wife's she was attacked in her home just
like Vanessa and both desperate to get
back to them Deadpool realizes that he
would go back and save Vanessa if he
could however he doesn't want to kill
Russell as he's just a kid instead he
just wants 30 seconds to try and change
Russell to take him away from that
darker path how about we see that's
going to be difficult to do as
juggernaut's now the guy that's acting
as his mentor leaving a super siiz store
we can also see it's on fire showing
that Russell is close to getting his
first kill this will be when he gets a
taste for a and will become the man who
kills Cable's family CED out's cab and
Deadpool says I bet 50 years from now we
best his buddies which is a reference to
this from Days of Future Past so you
were always an [__] I take it we're
best buddies in the future Deadpool end
says boom spoiler
alert which is a call back this line
from the first film spoiler alert
pulling up to the X mansion Deadpool
plays a mini boom box with a song being
In Your Eyes by Peter Gabriel in the
first film he said he'd stand outside
Vanessa's house playing Careless Whisper
with both being referenced to the movie
say anything you might also notice that
taped up the suit as well with there
being a lot of it around the waist
because he got ripped a pot from here we
then arrive at the school and if you
recognize to see SS in r at the
playground then that's cuz they're from
a pretty big movie that is Terminator 2
where these being the same props used in
Sarah's nightmare Jugger also reveals at
this point so you wear that helmet
because your brother tries to read your
mind yeah but he's in a wheelchair so
even Steven now in the comics Juggernaut
and Professor XX are half brothers and
Professor Rex can of course read
people's minds getting out the cab
Deadpool says are you bear God it's me
Margaret with this being in a to this
line from the first film are you be God
it's me Margaret this was a reference to
a book about a girl getting her first
period but here it's changed to are you
bear God Russell also dresses like the
unibomber and we watch as they attack
the school this leads to Juggernaut
attacking them and Deadpool jumps on his
back he says hey big guy the sun's
getting real low which is of course not
to what Black Widow says to Hulk to try
and comment down this was later RI on in
Thor Ragnarok with both this and that
failing to work you also get a stuck
sound effect Wilhelm scream which if
you're fan of films you you'll have no
doubt heard a gazilion
times I also love how the music in the
background is just some quiet shouting
how it's a juggernaut and it's such a
cool scene and pale through the head we
then hear some lovely music with
Deadpool swooning over Colossus this is
a call back to the first film in which
he had something similar happen on the
not heli carrier while looked at Vanessa
Deadpool then tells him to go sweep the
leg which is a call back to the karate
kid he then says go get him tiger which
is a reference to what Mary Jane often
says to Spider-Man along with it being
something said throughout the first film
go get her tiger big CGI fight May at
this point leading to all the orderes
being taken out in the blood bath shout
outs to hasb on RIT for pointing out
that at the hour 45 Mark we can catch
cable shooting someone in the head which
sprays Blood on the camera Deadpool
looks at this blood and then turns in
Cable's Direction because he can see
where the shot came from Deadpool ends
up saving Russell from going down that
dark path and jugen or is seemingly
electrocuted to death however colossa
says he's just knocked out in the final
lines and in the last shot you can see
something's going on at the pool zooming
in on it you can see him climbing out
confirming that the juggernaut's still
around cuz he's the Juggernaut [__]
terrible Impressions and that's why
everyone hates the channel more than the
other better breakdown channels the
Deadpool ends up saving Russell from
getting shot sh used his head instead of
his heart strapping on the col then
makes it so he's the one who has to be
his first kill if Russell's willing to
do that then he's definitely going to be
the bad guy but Deadpool sacrifice shows
him there's good people Colossus says no
weight because of you which is a
reference to the movie Field of Dreams
the film is further alluded to in these
death moments with Wade asking if
they're in heaven biggest challenge of
your life will be trying to watch Field
of Dreams without crying and the whole
group does it while Deadpool dies drags
on forever though and you can kind of
see everyone getting fed up the longer
it goes on so funny in the extended Cod
cuz they just keep going and going and
going but finally finally he passes into
the Afterlife like get a move on mate
now it's from here that we get some
major alterations from the theatrical
card as originally we had an acoustic
version of a hard's Take On Me the song
was used on the Blu-ray menu with it
also appearing in some of the opening
scenes they switched it to the 2017
version with them jender flipping the
video so here it's the man being pulled
through the barrier Vanessa is the one
that pulls him through but he gets
sucked back because cable ends up saving
him now as for the music in the super
duper extended car it's a version of out
of the ashes with Wade asking if every
day can be International women's day
that's a call back to the first movie
happy International women's day sh says
kiss me like you miss me red with
Vanessa then jumping into his arms like
how she did at the beginning saved by
cable putting the token over his heart I
was wondering yell how how strong is
that token but it's made from Real Lead
and uh yeah we save some from other Le
and we then end with dopinder getting
his hero moment he kills the head master
and finally this family is together with
cable staying in the past or present now
going to the credits as the little
pictures Fall Away we get a map of
Vancouver which is where Ryan RS is from
from here we go to the post credit scene
with them fixing up the watch this
allows Deadpool to travel through time
and eras all his mistakes firstly he
saves Vanessa which leech said he wanted
to have confirmed due to not allowing
the audience to leave on a big bummer
note he also saves pet and says Fox
basically created the X Force so legally
they could keep cable as one of their
properties we were then going to get a
scene of him urinating on Shadow star's
grave but they decided to just cut it
from the film you also get some archive
footage of X-Men Origins with Deadpool
asking Hugh Jackman to get back in the
sdle if he asks him as we know that's
going to be Deadpool 3 and he also
shoots and kills Ryan Reynolds reading a
green ltin script saved us from that and
honestly it's the greatest post credit
scene of all time topped off by Deadpool
warming up to kill B Adolf we see him
whining up and clapping his hands
witching itself a not to naal Lampoons
this is what Clark rwal did before he
got in the Poo with Christine Brinkley
which is also something that took
maximum effort right at the end it's
revealed Deadpool didn't kill him and
he's going to go get cable to come do it
cuz he loves killing kids that closes
out the film and the movie also stepped
things up visually with him realizing
after the first one that the mouth
didn't move much thus for this film R
did two takes for every scene with one
being with the mask and the other being
without it this gave them a better
Foundation of how to animate it with it
having way more subtleties than what we
got last time you also have Colossus
appearing more angular as well with them
updating the model from that first film
over the credits we have Team headkick
rapping about xforce with them providing
the Deadpool rap in the first film and
also in the game got a claim on the
first breakdown for playing that so I
don't want to risk it but go check it
out on YouTube cuz it's a pretty cool
song also forgot to mention that when
cable reveals these from the future
Deadpool asks what Shar NATO they're on
this is later picked up in the last
shock NATO it's about time there when
they travel to the Future they ask what
Deadpool movie they're on which is a
nice franchise callback going back and
forth between the two but sadly the film
was an old sunshine in rainbows and joy
Harris lost her life while she was
filming it standing in is a stunt double
for Domino she unfortunately died in the
motor by crash the movie is dedicated to
her and it's always devastating hearing
about these kinds of stories her Legacy
of course lives on no and this is a
movie that's brought happiness to
Millions I hope you guys have enjoyed it
too and I've had a lots of fun breaking
down these two films as of making this
the Deadpool tree trailer hasn't been
released yet but I can't wait to dive
into it once it hits the interweb as
with all our big breakdowns like this
you can get early access to them by
becoming members all the cost is 99
Cents and 99 a month and you'll get all
these before anybody else huge thank you
to everyone who signed up and we really
appreciate all the support if you want
some else to watch then check out our
right on the first film which we go over
all Easter eggs in that huge thank you
for Sing to the video I'm exhausted but
I'll see you next time you've been the
best I've been Paul as always and I hope
you have a good week have a bloody good
one and enjoy that trailer if you're
from the future and you've seen the
trailer let me know if the trailer's
good take care yourself I love you guys
peace